tracez une photo nh alors c'est quoi ces
noms c'est quel siècle rappelle qu'on
est dans les mêmes mots j'ai été moi
donc si vous êtes grossièrement vous
êtes grossier avec la vie est injuste
c'est ma première photo d'identité est
la seule au contraire où j'étais pas y
de ce que j'étais tellement moche qu'on
me faisait baisser la tête pudiquement
qu'on ne voit pas le moins possible et
donc là c'est la seule potable où
j'étais moi je leur disais moi créé dieu
quand j'étais c'était ok 2012 c'est quoi
les cinq ans métier vous étiez arrivé si
je savais qu'on tait sale odeur fais ton
bâton ou c'était chaud dedans
photographies chez un photographe qui
arrive en traction angoisses et vous ça
oui oui cette raison de ma soeur qui
pose ici c'est la viande parce que la
grève était en fait quand même deux
bouffées mais presque parfait comme ça
confie que vous avez peur de très belles
là c'était le seul mois où j'avais
grossi j'étais passé à sale combien vous
étiez passé comme 55 kg alors que je
fais car on a déjà très remontée contre
amiens va pas au fait combien la
parachever 49 50
non question choyé vraiment vous aviez
vous mettre sur une balance 49,50 était
malade et français yannick jadot
là c'est mon délire s'ils passent
souvent que les meufs sur mon délire
mais là ça saigne et des iraniens
moi j'adore les femmes 1 alors les
granola
à grenoble nous échappé belle